dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here in this
piece of work
you see wondrous little sequences of
animations where a virtual character is
asked to write on a whiteboard move
boxes and perform different kinds of
sitting behaviors the emphasis is on
synthesizing believable footstep
patterns for this character this sounds
a bit mundane but we'll quickly realize
that the combination and blending of
different footstep styles is absolutely
essential for a realistic animation of
these tasks beyond simple locomotion
walking if you will for instance
sidestepping using toe and heel pivots
or partial turns and steps every now and
then are essential in obtaining a proper
posture for a number of different tasks
a rich vocabulary of these movement
types and proper transitions between
them lead to really amazing animation
sequences that you can see in the video
for instance one of the most heinous
examples of the lack of animating proper
locomotion we can witness in older
computer games and sometimes even today
is when a character is writing on a
whiteboard who suddenly runs out of
space turns away from it walks a bit
turns back towards the whiteboard and
continues writing there even if we have
impeccable looking photo realistically
rendered characters such robotic
behaviors really ruin the immersion in
reality a simple sidestepping would do
the job and this is exactly what the
algorithm tells the character to perform
very simple and smooth this technique
works by decomposing a given task to
several subtasks like starting to sit on
a box or getting up in choosing the
appropriate footstep types in
transitions for them one can also mark
different tasks as being low or high
effort that are marked with green and
blue a low effort task could mean fixing
a minor error on the whiteboard nearby
without moving there and a high effort
task that we see marked with blue would
be continuing our writing on a different
part of the whiteboard for these tasks
the footsteps are planned accordingly
really cool this piece of work is a
an example of the depth and complexity
of computer graphics and animation
research and how even the slightest
failure in capturing fine scale details
is enough to break the immersion of
reality it is also really amazing that
we have so many people who are
interested in watching these videos
about research and quite a few of you
decided to also support us on patreon I
feel really privileged to have such
amazing supporters like you fellow
scholars as always I kindly thank you
for this at the end of these videos so
here goes thanks for watching and for
your generous support and I'll see you
next time
you